on trouve le
fameux prédateurs donc là j'en ai vu
c'est tout ce qui flotte
[Musique]
alors les bons gestes de prévention sont
recouvrir d'abord les fûts de
récupération d'eau de pluie donc cédé
souvent les fugues bleus dans lesquels
on récupère de l'eau voilà look est
précieuse pour les jardiniers donc on
peut le recouvrir de manière bien
hermétique parce que le moustique c'est
un tout petit moustique donc soit avec
un couvercle qui sera adapté soit avec
les moustiquaires et un tendeur et voilà
faire en sorte que qui aucun pays aucune
petite fente aucun petit trou qui lui
permettent de rentrer dans le vif pour
pondre ses oeufs
de manière générale donc des moustiques
on appelle moustiques autochtone qui se
développe en milieu naturel on l'est
pour est une vague les roselières etc
oui on n'a plus cette année parce qu'on
a eu des pluies depuis le mois de m et
puis incessantes qui ont fait gonfler
les cours d'eau le rhin et d'autres
cours d'eau traverse la plaine rhénane
là on est actuellement mois d'août la
période on en a plus avec le mois de
septembre
on a un pic d'activité actuellement des
moustiques tiques des fois je fume pas
des fois je j'achète un paquet de ces
gable des cigarettes pour femmes qui
meurent attaque il des fois je mets des
binaires dans les bras ils mouillent
dans la figure
[Musique]